went into the decision to kick the field
goal there on fourth and eight and do
you regret that in hindsight
yeah any time it doesn't work out you
always regret it right but
uh it was just the circumstances of
having three shots
and coming away with no yards um
and knowing that you not only need the
touchdown but you'd need the two point
so the way i was looking at it was
we essentially had four timeouts with
the two minute warning
and you know we we knew we needed to get
a stop
and i thought we were going to have a
stop there at the end but you know they
we got cold for
for the pi um
and it didn't work out so i think any
time
something doesn't work out do you regret
it
sure but we're always going to be
process driven here and the way our
defense was battling
the way our defense was playing felt
like it was the right decision to do
and it just didn't work out
yeah that wasn't my decision but i
understand
thinking about two minutes with all of
our timeouts but
yeah that wasn't my decision maddy
allowed me to call that third down play
um if i had known we were going to kick
it if we
get it you know maybe something else
would have been
maybe gone with uh some sort of uh you
know crossing routes maybe there
uh instead but i thought we you know
maybe we're gonna have four chances to
go
rob demofsky erin i don't know how it
exactly works in the heat of the moment
but is there any
opportunity to try to convince matt to
go for it
in that situation on fourth and eight or
is that not even possible
yeah i mean i don't i don't know that's
tough one rob
yeah i look over silent i see you know
five big guys around the field
there's a lot of gymnastics that has to
happen to get us
you know to be able to go for it there
but yeah
yeah um i don't know that decision was
made and we when
moved on
now look i've seen quarterbacks in the
past in the midst of those gymnastics
involving five big guys coming out for
the field goal team
say this go back we're going for it
lamar jackson did it famously last year
in the seahawks
ravens game where the 2019 ravens really
landed on our radar screen as a
legitimate force
if worst case uh scenario happens and
you don't have enough time you got three
timeouts i mean this is about trying to
tie the game not conserve your timeouts
and i i look
i i don't want to blame aaron rodgers
for it because he's just deferring to
the structure he's a part of what matt
lafleur said
we're always going to be driven by
process i don't know what that means
all i know is this and i wrote about
this today at pft it dawned on me as i
was thinking about this
what matt lafleur did in that one moment
shireen he
underestimated two of the greatest
quarterbacks
in league history he underestimated the
ability of aaron rodgers
to make the play with the season on the
line and he underestimated the ability
of tom brady to deliver the dagger
when given the opportunity to hold the
lead of five points with two minutes
left
no question mike and it was a very good
post
and that was my argument too
do you trust aaron rodgers more or do
you trust your defense more to stop tom
brady
and to me you trust aaron rodgers more
in that situation and frankly mike
if they don't get it there the bucks are
on the eight
yard line i would much rather like i
would much
i would like my chances more from the
eight yard line
stopping them because maybe the bucks
are more careful in that situation
maybe they don't throw the ball on first
now i don't know but
i would have liked to have seen them go
for it
and even if you don't get it at least
the bucks are taking over the ball on
the eight yard line and to me you would
have had it
perhaps a better chance to get the ball
back
than what you had yeah we saw tom brady
converting
third downs all game long there were
just two punts for the tampa bay
buccaneers now there were
three consecutive brady interceptions on
three straight drives
two of those may have ended up in punts
one was in field goal range
but when you consider all the
circumstances see this is why i don't
like predetermined
organizational situational football
decisions where
you think about it ahead of time and if
we ever get in this situation this is
what we're gonna do
this much time on the clock this down
and distance this field position press
the button
this is what you do because we've
already done the research ahead of time
you've got to consider the bigger
picture here the buccaneers were up
18 it was over and then here come the
packers
they make it close they make it
interesting they get it to 28 to 23.
then the bucks get the field goal to
make it 31-23 i mean
the packers almost did to the buccaneers
what the seahawks did to the packers six
years ago when the packers had their
ticket punched
for a tom brady aaron rodgers super bowl
and it fell apart for the packers the
packers could have done that they could
have pulled it off so
if your process says in that situation
we're going to trust our defense
and take the field goal your process has
to take a hike
in that setting when you're at home
the season's on the line you were down
18
and you got them on their heels and you
got one of the great quarterbacks of all
time
with one play one play and see i was
pissed off about it this morning and i
still
am sorry london if this is on in london
i don't think it is but i'm still pissed
off about it shireen because
we collectively we all of us were
deprived
of that moment of that moment of the
buccaneers defense getting into
formation
the packers offense coming up to the
line of scrimmage joe buck and troy
aikman or the radio
folks if you're listening you know to
the partisans who call the games
whatever it is
a rare special moment game is on the
line
it's fourth and goal from the eight the
green bay packers against the tampa bay
buccaneers brady and rogers it all comes
down to this
unless it doesn't it still upsets me and
i don't want to be selfish
but i speak on behalf of all football
fans when i say matt lafleur
you screwed all of us
well and mike i felt so much i'm
nonpartisan in both of these games but
i felt the tenseness of that situation i
mean i'm just like who's going to win
this game it's going to come
when they kick the field goal i'm like
bucks are going to win this game
i don't see the packers getting the ball
back with enough time to dr and i
realized this aaron rodgers but it was
also tom brady on the other side which
goes to your point you got to know who's
on this
other side of the ball the browns
against the
the cheese patrick mahomes on the other
side you don't punt in that situation
bills you don't kick field goals in that
situation patrick mahomes is on the
other side he averages 36 points
in the playoff in playoff games he
started and finished so
know who's on the other side of the ball
don't just look at some
chart as you said predetermined and mike
let's go back
also to the two-point conversion they
went for if they don't go in analytics
in that situation
says go for it i get it there's a place
for analytics
but i'm just saying if you kick the
extra point at that point
you only need the seven points and your
chances of
tying that game and sending into
overtime go up
not down now if they'd gotten a
two-point conversion it would have been
completely different but
saint brown dropped the pass that was
slightly tipped at the line
and and here we are talking about they
needed the touchdown and the two-point
conversion and i know analytics in that
situation from what i saw
their chances of winning didn't change
much whether they kicked the field or
went for it
but i would have liked their chances
better with aaron rodgers in that
situation from the eight yard line
one player and and even though
leflore pointed to the pass interference
as the reason
for extending the drive and allowing the
buccaneers to win the game well
that's one of the risks you assume when
you let them have the ball yeah one of
the possibilities is
they're going to pick up a first down
via a penalty it's going to happen
potentially or somebody's going to pop
through the line of scrimmage and run
for a first down or tom brady's going to
hit
there's 20 different things that could
happen that will beat you
once you let tom brady have the ball
again and you accept the possibility
that one of those is going to happen
what happened was it was the past
interference call not a bad call
the only reason people are upset is
because they were calling it
loose all game long and then all of a
sudden they decide to call it tight even
though it really isn't calling it tight
when as somebody told me on twitter
today kevin king turned
tyler johnson's l into an xl the way he
ripped at the back of it and
you know impeded his ability to go get
the ball so and there's a question
whether or not it was catchable but one
of the reasons wasn't catchable is a guy
was
held from trying to get closer to catch
the ball so
that's the risk you take when you don't
say
i trust my guy
and i fear their guy
i mean i've never seen this before i've
seen coaches underestimate their own
players before
but to underestimate rogers
and in turn underestimate brady is one
of a kind and
this feels like one of those that just
like
rogers comments the more time passes the
more it's going to stink
and the more people are going to say
what the hell happened and this is going
to be a little bit bit of a mess that
matt lafleur has to clean up
in green bay and it may be one of the
reasons why aaron rodgers is thinking
you know hey i carry this team all year
long
and then we get to the point where the
season is on the line
and i don't get the opportunity i mean
have i not
done enough to merit
the opportunity to convert on fourth and
goal from the eight if we don't get it
it's on me
i'll take the blame but i think i've
earned the right
to be the one to make that play that
that's probably one of the reasons why
he was so dejected after the game
and guess what mike you talked about the
past interference penalty i was yelling
this when i was watching matt lafleur
maybe the same thing happens on the
fourth thing goal play
maybe you get the defensive hold or the
defensive pass interference and guess
what you've got
first in goal from the one not only can
you score the touchdown and kick the
extra
and get the two-point conversion but you
might be able to run the time down
as well so you know what he had a chance
right there
to to make history and instead aaron
rodgers makes history in a different way
becoming
the first quarterback first starting
quarterback to lose four consecutive
championship games like that and and he
didn't give
rogers the chance in this game and there
were multiple
coaching errors in this game that
obviously was the biggest but that
we are overshadowing and forgetting
about the one right before the half
which may have been the play of the game
yeah the scottie miller no risk it no
biscuit touchdown throw where i don't
know what the jets
are the jets i'm thinking the jets
because i'm thinking greg williams i
don't know what
the packers were thinking mike penton
used to be with the jets
no two safeties deep wasn't really
guarding the sidelines against the out
and kevin king let scottie miller run by
him for that touchdown and
that was the look that that's all the
more reason to go
for it on fourth and goal from the eight
yeah because when scotty miller catches
that ball
that game feels over and then the fumble
by aaron jones
to start the second half and the buck
score again it's definitely over
they were on the brink of pulling off
what history would have remembered as
one of the great comebacks of all time
in postseason nfl annals
and they opted not to let one of the
great quarterbacks of all time
get it done i'm telling you the more i
think about it the more it upsets me
so my guess is the more aaron rodgers
and other packers players
think about it especially on the offense
the more it's going to upset them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports